but internally I do not have to do it or it has been
it will be the town
united states that badoer
alternative expression
but with bolivia
and I had a lot of hope
kiev 1 american fire discriminated
there was another
indigenous peasant leader discriminated together we could work
for justice for equality
not only two countries like Bolivia and the United States and not
for equality around the world
then in Bolivia leaves much to be desired
for example the issue of desertification of the fight against
drug trafficking
without him obama recognizes before the national congress
what the goal that we have contributed our economic resource
congratulated the national police for the
by
min the seizure of drug
recognizes the peaceful efforts we make in the production of
Coke
however desertifies
fidel who decertifies the government of the united states because united states
cocaine demand grows
increasingly clandestine or factories
of synthetic drugs
percent
The Rossoneri is expected to grow 1 percent of coca cultivation in
bolivia obama says
that here comes mori there has been a growth of 9 percent of the crop
coca
systems of believing united nations
juan state department of the united states I believe of course the nations
united
as avatar and jyber sando
in numbers
the net result accounting puerto rico for what
to accuse and accuse labor of the conaculta africa
Regrettably
in this obama government
accusation of drug trafficking and terrorism
for emo
drug trafficking
but little
terrorism
evo morals percuss son hugo chávez terrorism
we are instruments
from ee
3 accusation
but as a goal of how he prepared a control in those countries
maybe militarily as he did in
english
the one that resided
Saddam Hussein had massive weapons of destruction to mankind
with that intervening pretext comes
militarily
is the only thing he does is like you ap I will not be from those new fields
tankers
the oil wells
what are geopolitical interests to be
behind the so-called fight against drug trafficking or
percent
The terrorism
percent other topics
we fulfill them with everything we can do as bolivia
the fight against drug trafficking
but nevertheless
It takes away the tariff preferences
rises with economic sabotage bolivia
but thanks to the solidarity of Argentina
from brazil especially from venezuela now we sell
he improved his budget ie textiles
in South America to the United States
Of course
many mistakes but that market but only wants
soto way to economically block Bolivia the other pint or
and thanks to the solidarity of South America better pretending others
three civilians
the three brothers